bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne
l'audition de rémy pflimlin le pdg de
france télévisions il est entendu par
les sénateurs de la commission de la
culture sur le comme le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens de france
télévisions
cette audition intervient alors que le
budget 2013 votée par l'assemblée
nationale prévoit une baisse de la
dotation de france télévisions de 2,3
pour cent
même si les députés ont voté une
augmentation de 4 euros de la redevance
ils n'ont en revanche pas retenu l'idée
de la mise en place d'une demi
redevances sur les résidences
secondaires tout de suite donc
l'audition de rémy pflimlin bonne
matinée à tous nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour entendre comme chaque
année sur le bilan de l'exécution du
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens signés
entre l'état et france télévisions pour
la période 2011-2015 pour entendre
monsieur rémy films cette année encore
nos collègues de la commission des
finances ne peuvent se joindre à nous
compte tenu du calendrier budgétaire
très particulier de cette session
postélectorale nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion monsieur le pdg de vous
entendre le 4 avril dernier dans le
cadre des travaux de la commission pour
le contrôle de l'application des lois
présidée par notre collègue david
assouline qui est ici présents qui a
donné lieu à un rapport d'information
sur l'application de la loi 2009
relative à l'audiovisuel public
mais l'actualité riche en interrogation
concernant non seulement l'exécution du
com mais le financement de france
télévisions et je ne doute pas que nos
collègues ont de nombreuses questions à
vous poser aujourd'hui sachez que je
suis destinataires de nombreux courriers
les gens s'associent aux questionnements
posés par la suppression de la pub
cité par la compensation diminué et qui
altèrent vos recettes par le marché de
la publicité mais ses nombreux courriers
interroge également sur le plan social
sur les départs 10 volontaires sur les
conséquences des réductions budgétaires
pour de futurs départs volontaires et
sur le recours structurel à des non
titulaires et qu'en adviendra-t-il pour
le futur d'autre part nous avons appris
dans les médias comme n'importe qui la
fusion des rédactions de france 2 et
france 3 et le parlement auraient aimé
l'apprendre de votre bouche puisque nous
vous avions attendu plutôt qu'à la radio
voilà monsieur film là nous vous
écoutons
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les circonstances de cette
audition son cette année tout à fait
particulière je suis en effet conduit à
vous rendre compte de la première année
de mise en oeuvre d'un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens signés il y a
moins d'un an en novembre de l'an passé
et a évoqué avec vous la perspective de
sa mise en cause telle qu'elle découle
inévitablement du niveau des ressources
qui semble devoir être celle de france
télévisions en 2013
aux termes du projet de loi de finances
en cours de discussion je vais revenir
sur 2011 car il est primordial que
chacun est à l'esprit que le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens 2011-2015 a
considérablement renforcé les missions
de france télévisions
ces missions contracté avec l'état après
avis du parlement
nous les avons rempli en 2011 dans un
contexte déjà de baisse de nos
ressources nous les rempliront en 2012
dans un contexte encore de baisse de nos
ressources nous les rempliront car elles
sont au coeur de notre action et parce
que cette entreprise est gérer et
piloter dans le même temps j'ai la
conviction profonde
l'heure de la réforme est venue d'abord
parce que france télévisions est animé
par un esprit de solidarité
dans le contexte économique de notre
pays mais aussi parce que je veux saisir
cette contrainte qui s'abat sur nous et
sur bien d'autres dans ce pays pour en
faire une opportunité pour renforcer
notre capacité à nous projeter dans
l'avenir pour accélérer une stratégie de
modernisation qui porte ses fruits
notamment dans les domaines essentiels
de l'information et du numérique
mais je vous dois cette vérité en 2013
l'ampleur et la brutalité de l'effort
qui semble devoir être demandée à
l'entreprise ne sera pas tenable sans
dommage sur son équilibre économique
nice en révision en profondeur des
objectifs essentiels que nous assigne
est notre contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens
brièvement quelques chiffres le plf en
l'état prévoit une régression de 87
millions d'euros soit 3,4 pour cent des
concours publics alloués à france
télévision versus -0 3% en moyenne pour
les autres sociétés de l'audiovisuel
public dans un contexte publicitaire
critique les ressources commerciales
s'annonce en baisse de 67 millions
d'euros
ce sont donc au total plus de 150
millions d'euros soit 5,1 pour cent de
nos ressources de moins qu'au budget
2012 beaucoup de choses ont été
entendues ces dernières semaines sur
france télévisions et son financement
je souhaite y revenir car nous avons le
sentiment que les présentations injuste
qu'elle le soit de bonne foi ou non
brouille l'appréhension sereine de ce
débat
l'évolution favorable de la redevance
tout d'abord 4 euros de mieux pour
assurer la pérennité du financement de
l'audiovisuel public et le france
télévisions dont la part redevances du
financement progresse de 109 millions
d'euros
non car la part de son financement issu
du budget général régresse lui
concomitamment 296 millions d'euros le
budget général de l'état se trouve
l'ag de presque 2 200 millions d'euros
par ce fait les options un temps
envisagée et que nous voulons croire
encore envisageable qu'elle porte sur le
taux ou sur l'assiette de la redevance
doivent-elles légitimement être écartée
au motif qu'elle exonèrerait france
télévisions de tout effort s'il ne
m'appartient pas de répondre sur le fond
à la place du parlement j'attire
simplement votre attention sur le fait
que de telles mesures
les serait en toute hypothèse
l'entreprise selon les options retenues
au minimum entre 50 et 100 millions
d'euros sous son budget 2012 en valeur
nous allons quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive réaliser le grand plan
d'économies de l'histoire de la
télévision publique sur les recettes
publicitaires et nous est régulièrement
objecté qu'elle était surévalué que le
com était sur ce point un sincère puis
je rappeler qu'il y a un an
le débat budgétaire se concentrait sur
la question des excédents publicitaire
de france télévisions et que le contexte
du lancement de six nouvelles chaînes
tnt gratuite puis du rachat de deux
chaînes de la tnt par le groupe canal+
est intervenue postérieurement à la
négociation du come on me parle aussi du
fait que ce serait l'insuffisance de nos
efforts de gestion qui justifierait à
elle seule que l'entreprise soit mise
sous pression mise en quelque sorte en
demeure de se réformer structurellement
pour ce qui concerne 2011 la trajectoire
du com a été respecté la priorité a été
donnée aux dépenses de programmes les
charges hors programmes ont été réduites
et le résultat est à l' équilibre
ceci malgré des ressources en baisse
pour 2012 face à une dégradation plus
importante encore de nos ressources nous
avons engagé dès la fin du premier
semestre un plan d'économies de 30
millions d'euros
les audits de production sur les
programmes ont été amplifiés nous avons
ainsi réalisé 7 millions d'euros
d'économies sur les grilles de rentrée
des dizaines de contrats d'achat hors
programmes ont été renégocié à la baisse
de parfois plusieurs millions d'euros
des mesures toujours plus énergiques
sont en cours d'élaboration pour
investir toutes les marches possible et
je suis le premier à ne pas contester
qu'il n'en existe encore à les investir
dans les contenus
mais je ne peux pas laisser croire que
france télévisions disposerait depuis
des années en sous main et donc à l'insu
de son seul actionnaire d'un matelas qui
lui permettraient d'absorber du jour au
lendemain
150 à 200 millions de réduction de son
budget au delà de ce que cette opinion
peut avoir d' injuste pour les
collaborateurs de france télévisions
mais aussi d'offensant pour l'ensemble
des administrations de l'état qui la
contrôle au delà de ce qu'elle peut
avoir de choquant pour l'idée que nous
nous faisons de notre responsabilité
collective dans la gouvernance d'une
entreprise publique une telle assertion
est à la fois erronée et risque et elle
est erronée si elle repose sur l'idée
que les synergies issues de l'entreprise
unique peuvent éclore en un jour
rappelons le cette entreprise a été mise
en chantier en janvier 2010 en situation
de fusion juridique dans un état
d'impréparation manifeste dont elle
continue aujourd'hui à payer le prix
l'entreprise unique était et reste une
nécessité mais unifiée huit sociétés 14
chaînes avec les outre-mers 10000
collaborateurs que l'histoire a conduit
à se construire en opposition les unes
aux autres
cela demande du temps du temps pour
négocier les statuts collectif pour
exposer la nouvelle organisation aux
instances et au personnel pour
rapprocher fluidifier les procédures et
outils de travail pour regrouper
physiquement les collaborateurs des
nouveaux services communs rappeler ces
évidences ce n'est pas nous défausser
c'est encore moi nous dédouaner de tout
effort de gestion c'est dire et redire
qu'il est matériellement socialement
humainement techniquement impossible
qu'une fusion d'une telle ampleur soit
génératrice d'économies massive dans un
temps si court 2011 et le 1er semestre
2012 ont marqué d étape importante dans
la construction de l'entreprise comme
une poursuite des négociations sociales
et signature de deux accords collectifs
essentielle journaliste temps de travail
qui doivent nous permettre d'aboutir à
la conclusion à la fin de l'année d'un
accord indispensable pour
l'harmonisation des statuts poursuite
des chantiers cruciaux de convergence
des outils informatiques de gestion mise
en place d'un organigramme lisible
donnant sa place à chaque collaborateur
ces travaux doivent pouvoir se
construire et se poursuivre à un rythme
réaliste or nous prenons le risque de
briser cette nouvelle dynamique
essentielle et à la mise en oeuvre des
synergies que la collectivité est
effectivement en droit d'attendre de
l'entreprise unique mais je reviens à la
dimension éditorial du projet que
portait le contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens afin que chacun ait en tête ce
que nous avons réalisé et qui est
aujourd'hui susceptibles d'être mises en
cause nous avons cherché à renforcer les
identités respectives de chacune des
antennes de france télévisions tout en
nous projetant sur les territoires
nouveaux et jusque là sous investis du
numérique
cette ambition s'est déclinée en termes
de présence territoriale
d'investissement dans la création
d'information et de sport ainsi que le
développement de nos plus petites
chaînes et enfin enjeu hautement
stratégique dans la conquête des usages
numériques de nos concitoyens notre
présence territoriale tout d'abord en
métropole france 3 est la chaîne du lien
social entre des concitoyens que les
chaînes commerciales délaisse car ce ne
sont pas des cibles publicitaires en
2011 le volume de diffusion régionale de
france 3 a crû de plus de 30% et le coût
horaire des programmes régionaux a
baissé de 20%
nous devons certainement encore
améliorer notre efficacité et notre
organisation
mais contrairement à ce que j'entends
trop souvent france 3 n'est pas un
problème pour france télévisions mais un
atout à l'heure du choix budgétaires
drastiques
nous devrons déterminer tous ensemble ce
que nous entendons par proximité ce que
nous en attendons pour nos territoires
et pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens en
outre-mer un défi considérable a été
relevé par deux équipes en à peine plus
d'un an avec la rive
la tnt fin 2010 transformer les ex
télépays de rfo dont les grilles reposer
à 80% sur les programmes des chaînes
publiques nationales enchaîne doté de
programmation trois quarts spécifique
dans le contexte concurrentiel très
dense d outre-mer ces chaînes renommée
outre mer 1ère font aujourd'hui l'objet
d' attaque public extrêmement violente
et mensongères des chaînes locales
privées
là encore il nous faudra en conscience
et en responsabilité définir ce que la
collectivité attend de la présence du
service public audiovisuel dans ces
territoires
évoquant ensuite les programmes dits de
création c'est-à-dire la fiction le
documentaire le spectacle vivant et
l'animation en 2011 notre groupe a
atteint un niveau historique
d'investissement de 416 millions d'euros
dans la production d'oeuvres
audiovisuelles et près de 63 millions
d'euros de soutien au cinéma
france télévisions soutien à elle seule
aujourd'hui près de 60 % des
investissements nationaux dans la
création et par ce biais l'économie et
l'emploi de toute une filière
je les ai indiqué vendredi dernier lors
des rencontres cinématographiques de
dijon
il ne nous sera pas possible de
poursuivre avec un tel niveau
d'engagement dans un contexte budgétaire
aussi dégradée j'en profite pour
m'inscrire en faux contre une idée trop
facilement reçu à l'heure actuelle selon
laquelle les programmes de france
télévisions n'offrent plus cette marque
de qualité de culture qui a fait depuis
toujours la fierté du service public
nous devons certainement accentué encore
notre différenciation
depuis que la tnt a créé une hyper
concurrence qui donne la part belle à
des programmes ayant pour finalité le
profit je ne juge pas la logique des
chaînes commerciales mais il est
largement admis que la tnt n'a pas
enrichi qualitativement l'offre
audiovisuelle de notre pays nous devons
également mieux faire savoir
nos offres dans ce monde nous sommes
tous sur sollicités nous devons enfin
renforcer la spécificité de chacune de
nos chaînes
l'une par rapport à l'autre
mais gardons à ce débat objectivité et
rigueur à chaque instant sur les
antennes de la télévision publique nos
concitoyens trouve des programmes
qu'aucune chaîne commerciale ne
proposera jamais et qui peuvent
l'enrichir culturellement et
émotionnellement à travers notre socle
commun de valeurs et aux heures de plus
grande écoute
notre devoir est de rassembler tous les
âges tous les milieux toutes les
origines prenons pour seul exemple mais
il pourrait y en avoir bien d'autres
la soirée du 17 octobre et la confiance
obtenu par huit millions et demi de nos
concitoyens devant la fiction médecin
chef à la santé sur france 2 adapté de
l'essai du docteur vasseur traitant de
l'état de nos prisons et le magazine des
racines et des ailes sur france 3 qui
nous emmenait ce jour là la découverte
du pays basque des exemples comme celui
ci j'en ai pour les 52 semaines de
l'année faites l'exercice
faites l'exercice d'ouvrir votre
programme télévision et vous en ferez
vous même l'expérience vous découvrirez
par exemple pour ce soir que france ton
france 2 propose une fiction française
originale et france 3 un documentaire
sur le président obama
évoquons maintenant nos réalisations en
matière d'information et de sport en
2011 et 2012
france télévisions est re devenue le
lieu du débat démocratique
nous avons recréé la seule grande
émission politique délai télévisuelle
des paroles et des actes fait progresser
l'audience de nos journaux accueilli
plus de 1000 heures de parole des
responsables politiques sur nos antennes
durant les élections contre quelques
dizaines d'heures chez nos concurrents
et converties sur l'internet fixe et
mobile seront retrouvés en matière
d'information france télévisions est
désormais premier devant tf1
sur l'ensemble des supports numériques
nous engageons maintenant avec thierry
thulliez et nos journalistes
le plan informations 2015 que vous avez
évoqué madame la présidente et qui
définira l'organisation permettant de
poursuivre l'adaptation de nos offres à
la façon nouvelle dont nos concitoyens
s'informent multipliant les sources
exigeant l'immédiateté la qualité
l'indépendance et une modernité de
traitement
cette annonce a d'ailleurs été faite
lors d'un comité central d'entreprise et
nous devions la priorité à nos salariés
dans le cadre évidemment des lois
sociales en en vigueur le service public
doit également garantir plus que jamais
un accès gratuit à nos concitoyens à des
programmes sportifs événementiels et
diversifiée 26 disciplines retransmise
en 2011 année nom d'olympic près de cent
dix disciplines traités dans nos
journaux et magazines
cet été près de 40 millions de français
ont regardé au moins une heure de
programme olympique sur les chaînes
publiques
ce n'est pas un luxe au profit de france
télévisions c'est la condition d'un
accès gratuit de tous à de très grands
moments de cohésion nationale mais aussi
à une diversité de disciplines populaire
mais délaissée par les sponsors
auxquelles seules les chaînes publiques
peuvent donner un écho 2011 est aussi
l'année de montée en puissance de france
ô france 4 et france 5 françois n'est
pas encore mesuré par médiamétrie
son nouveau cahier des charges l'a
conduit à rendre compte de la culture et
de l'actualité des outre mer mais
désormais bien plus que cela en
s'intéressant aux cultures européennes
africaines américaines et indiennes qui
passionne nombre de nos concitoyens sans
oublier les cultures urbaines de nos
villes sa contribution à la diversité et
la créativité du service public a
désormais reconnu par la presse alors
que la tnt accélère le vieillissement
des antennes historiques privés ou
publics
france 4 est devenu en 2011 notre
premier levier de conquête des jeunes
adultes + 23 % d'audience entre 2010 et
2011 + 35 % auprès des 15 34 ans des
résultats nettement meilleurs que ses
homologues privé pour un coût de grille
largement inférieurs enfin france 5 a vu
son audience croître de 7% en 2011
inversant la tendance d'une baisse
mécanique due à la tnt
cette chaîne incarne dans son domaine la
capacité d'alternative que représente le
service public face à la baisse
qualitative des offres de programmes
issus de la tnt comme je l'aï évoqué
précédemment avec une part de marché de
29 9% en 2011 qui progresse en 2012
nous sommes actuellement à 30 6% dans un
contexte concurrentiel inédit avec
beaucoup moins de chaînes et deux fois
moins de moyens que la bbc trois fois
moins que la télévision publique
allemande en stabilisant france 2 et
france 3 notamment grâce à l'information
et aux sports nous avons poursuivi une
ambition fondamentale une ambition et
non une obsession rester le premier
groupe audiovisuel français comme signe
de la confiance que les français font à
une télévision qu'ils financent
directement
nous y sommes parvenus sans dégrader la
qualité de nos offres comme le montrent
nos mesures de satisfaction de nos
téléspectateurs
j'évoque à notre succès en matière
d'information sur internet
au delà c'est bien la stratégie
numérique globale de france télévisions
dont le retard était unanimement pointé
il ya peu qui a pris son essor
trois quarts de nos programmes sont
désormais disponibles en rattrapage sur
pluzz notre groupe est passé en deux ans
de 7 à plus de 50 millions de vidéos
vues par mois
c'est le deuxième axe de notre stratégie
et c'est absolument crucial pour le
rayonnement de nos programmes et la
légitimité future du service public
à l'heure où nos concitoyens adoptant
nombre des pratiques numériques dans
l'univers déréglementé de la télévision
connectée ou nos concurrents se nomme
google et apple permet toi permettez moi
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
revenir pour conclure aux questions
d'avenir
il est à ce stade demandé à france
télévisions de réaliser en 2013 plus de
150 millions d'euros d'économies
mon devoir est de vous en informer le
plus solennellement comme je lai déjà
fait auprès de nos interlocuteurs du
gouvernement un tel volume d'économies
se sont bien plus de rediffusions c'est
la question de notre place en région et
en outre-mer se sont moins
d'investissements dans la création
ce sont des conséquences sévères sur
l'emploi à france télévision et dans les
secteurs qui vivent des commandes de
l'entreprise
enfin la situation actuelle conduirait
un déficit programmé de 80 à 100
millions d'euros en fin d'année
constituant un transfert paradoxal pour
une entreprise publique à laquelle il
est demandé de contribuer à l'effort
national d'assainissement des comptes
publics
la responsabilité de chef d'entreprise
êtes vous en alerter il appartient
désormais au gouvernement comme à la
représentation nationale dans le cadre
du projet de loi de finances de se
prononcer sur les moyens d'atteindre ce
juste équilibre que nous souhaitons tous
pour notre télévision publique
je vous remercie de votre attention
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et nous sommes prêts avec
mes collaborateurs ici présents à
répondre à toutes vos questions
merci monsieur rémy pfimlin je donne
tout de suite la parole aux rapporteurs
david et souligner merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président et des
films là parlons d'un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens effectivement
dans un contexte qui appelle forcément à
sa révision
puisque la situation financière nous
oblige à commencer par là pour savoir ce
qui est réalisable et ce qu'il convient
de réaliser dans les années qui viennent
pour france télévisions en préambule
vous ne le faites pas
mais je suis obligé de le faire c'est
que cette situation financière est issue
directement d'une décision de proposer
une réforme du financement de france
télévisions qui a conduit tout droit à
cette situation aggravée par la crise
plus générale de l'économie et des
finances de et deux du déficit de l'état
aggravée mais si nous devons faire
ensemble un petit retour en arrière
il y avait un financement qui reposait
sur la redevance
et qui reposait sur un autre pied la
publicité on n'était plus du tout dans
une discussion qui avait lieu au début
des années 2000 sur la difficulté de
financement de france télévisions nous
étions dans une situation saine
à ce moment là ou sur ses deux pieds
il y avait quelque chose qui avait
trouvé et sa stabilité sa viabilité et
aussi son indépendance on est venu dire
on supprime la publicité en pensant que
ça ferait le bonheur des chaînes privées
ça ne l'a pas fait complètement puisque
avec la tnt internet cette publicité qui
partait du service public s'est
dispersée beaucoup plus qu'on a là qu'on
ne la pensait en plus le taux de
taxation qui devait aller sur ses
publicités qui fuyaient vers le privé
après de multiples lobbying pression a
été telle qu'il n'a pas rapporté du tout
ce que l'on souhaitait pour france
télévisions une autre taxe et c'est là
qu'on rentre dans une grande incertitude
aux paysages que vous décrivez déjà très
difficile pour notre service public de
l'audiovisuel une autre taxe qui
rapporte aujourd'hui 350 millions et sur
lequel on peut compter risque de être
supprimés par décision finale de la
commission européenne
et l'année prochaine nous retrouver en
plus de ce que vous décrivez avec 350
millions de moins tout cela pour quoi
parce qu'on a décidé un jour quasi tout
seul le premier ministre n'était même
pas au courant qu'on supprimer la
publicité alors vais pas rentrer sur le
fond des grands changements éditoriaux
que cela produit la suppression de la
publicité je ne crois pas que france
télévisions avant était sous l'emprise
du commerce et ne faisait rien de
différent du que ce que faisait le privé
c'est pas vrai
et je ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui ça
soit plus ou moins le cas donc sur le
contenu de france télévisions il n'y a
pas eu de changement ni en mal
ni en bien et aujourd'hui personne
n'aperçoit complètement ce qui a fait la
grande différence notamment
on en a déjà parlé ensemble ici même le
ce démarrage de la publicité de deux des
programmes à 20h30 qui différenciait
france 2 le tout le reste
parce qu'on commence et on pouvait voir
deux programmes etc n'a pas été
pratiquée dans les faits au fur et à
mesure vous l'avait justifiée en disant
que vous pouviez pas tenir le
téléspectateur si vous faisiez chiper le
début de programme par notamment tf1 qui
pouvait faire des modules de dix minutes
et les garder ensuite
donc on a compris votre point de vue
mais en tous les cas ça venait
contredire une des raisons essentielles
pour lesquelles on nous disait il faut
commencer à 20h30 supprimer la publicité
le tunnel et avoir cette plage et cette
différence visible un carnet pour le
téléspectateur de l'audiovisuel public
donc je reviens juste sur la situation
financière
maintenant il est évident que dans
toutes les administrations dans toutes
les entreprises en public dans tous les
ménages
d'une certaine façon qu'ils ont les
moyens il faut faire tous un effort ce
que vous contestez où nous alerter c'est
que l'effort demandé brutalement risque
de déstabiliser les plans que vous
voulez faire de rationalisation étalé
dans le temps
je vous donne un satisfecit c'est que
c'est évident que l'entreprise unique et
la fusion l'entreprise unique et la
fusion ça doit permettre des économies
mais dans un premier temps ce n'est pas
les économies c'est forcément une part
d'investissement
d'accord l'état
aujourd'hui non seulement il ya pour la
redevance 2 euros de rattrapage par
rapport à l'augmentation de la vie je le
dis parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est naturel
mais à un moment donné si c'était une
bagarre pour faire admettre
parce que depuis 2002 le début des
années 2000 même ce rattrapage n'avait
plus lieu
donc il a lieu le gouvernement a proposé
dans son budget deux euros de plus pour
que tout le monde sache de quoi il
s'agit c'est 50 millions de plus 2 euros
c'est 50 millions de plus donc nous
avons là une proposition l'assemblée
vient de voter encore 2 euros ça veut
dire que la redevance la rapporter 100
millions de plus et d'accord hier il y
avait eu vote hier ou avant-hier jeu bon
donc il ya 100 millions moi je pense
qu'il faudra que le sénat viennent à
l'écouté de ce que vous avez dit et on
regarde ce qui est possible aujourd'hui
pour ne pas déstabiliser foncièrement
cette entreprise encore voter deux euros
de plus et 50 millions donc le plus pour
france télévisions ce qui répondrait à
votre demande vous dites que vous allez
être dans un déficit de 80 millions avec
l'état de la situation actuelle et bien
c'est trop important pour pouvoir ne pas
déstabiliser france télévisions je pense
qu'avec 30 millions c'est l'effort que
vous devez faire comme tout le monde
sans bousculer ni le périmètre ni les
plans est allé y compris de négociation
qu'il faut et là je rentre dans les
questions concrètes
parce que il faut une question concrète
sur les négociations sur le statut
collectif commun j'aimerais que vous
nous informez où on en est et qu'est ce
qui est prévu parce que les personnels
et l'ensemble de la maison et nous mêmes
nous interrogeons sur le rythme
il y a dans le comme un objectif sur les
4/14 ans et sur les jeunes l'audience
continue à baisser
de ce côté là enfin les audiences le le
le
la fréquentation de cette tranche d'âge
continuer à baisser et donc qu'est ce
qui est envisagé notamment c'est le
vieux débat sur l'identité de france 4
comment estimez vous l'évolution des
recettes publicitaires dans les trois
prochaines années puisque cette année
c'est moins 50 millions par rapport à
l'année dernière
est-ce que ça va se stabiliser est ce
que vous considérez que ça va
s'accroître
c'est vous avez certainement fait ce
type d'études prospectives et votre
estimation est elle encore conforme à
celle du contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens
je vous ai dit beaucoup de choses mais
en tous les cas je voulais d'abord
situer d'où vient le problème
il ya une loi qui a déstabilisé aggravée
par la crise financière l'état
aujourd'hui à fait non seulement
demandent les former a fait en sorte que
france télévisions puisse corriger ces
erreurs
pas de france télévisions mais commises
avec cette loi le sénat je lui
proposerai d'aller encore plus loin
parce que nous sommes attachés
fondamentalement à ce que nous avions
dit au cours du débat il ya deux ans à
ce que france télévisions reste un
service public de l'audiovisuel fort qui
imprime le paysage audiovisuel français
et qui reste dans son périmètre
parce qu'il n'y a pas trop de chaînes il
faut travailler sur l'identité
mais la bbc c'est plus de 20 chaînes
donc on arrête de dire peut-être il faut
renier là ou là non il faut préserver le
périmètre
il faut préserver sa place originale est
nécessaire pour le lien social et la
citoyenneté et nous sommes déterminés en
tous les cas à continuer ce qui a
toujours été de fait de façon
consensuelle au sénat et dans notre
commission défendre pied à pied
france télévisions
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vais
demander à monsieur rémy pfimlin de
réagir
ensuite nous avons déjà de nombreuses
questions monsieur raynaud madame morin
desailly mesdames gonthier-maurin
monsieur plancade madame blondin
monsieur le scouarnec ne surgiront le
gâteau la mèche est le monsieur legendre
allons-y je vais répondre aux trois
questions de monsieur leur apporteront
le remerciant pour ses paroles de
soutien et l'analyse qui fait d'eux de
la situation et et je leur dis comme je
l'aï dit dans mon propos introductif oui
france télévisions doit participer à
l'effort national
et oui nous devons poursuivre la réforme
avec vigueur alors dans cette réforme
avec vigueur
il y avait notamment un point central
vous l'avez souligné qui est la
négociation sur le statut collectif
c'est une négociation que nous menons
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois avec la
nécessité absolue d'aboutir pendant
cette année 2012 pour nous permettre à
partir de 2013 de commencer à travailler
avec un statut unique et donc en
rapprochant nos nos effectifs et en
faisant en sorte que le travail entre
les différentes entités soient plus
harmonieux j'ai demandé à patrice papet
qui est le patron des ressources
humaines et qui est directeur général
délégué aux questions d'organisation de
prendre la parole sur ce point là oui et
alors
en deux mots je vais essayer parce que
c'est une longue histoire la négociation
des accords collectifs elle était
engagée il ya plus de deux ans avec une
interruption fin 2010 pour des réseaux
d'élection c'est une négociation qui
avait initialement pour terme pour
échéance prévue juin 2010 et qui du fait
d'une décision de la cour d'appel de
paris a été reporté pour les
journalistes jusqu'à la milieu de
l'année 2011 et pour les
personnels techniques et administratifs
jusqu'à octobre 2012 donc on est on a
passé depuis quelques jours cette
deuxième échéance
on a tout au long de la négociation
accepté de proroger les accord pour
prolonger la discussion et c'est ce que
nous avons fait encore récemment puisque
le 8 octobre au soir dans qu'à la date
prévue du terme de négociations nous
avons avec trois des organisations
syndicales représentatives 3 sur 4
conclu un accord de prorogation jusqu'au
15 novembre pour finaliser les
discussions sur jallet dire un point
essentiel concernant le statut des
personnels qui est les classifications
et les rémunérations
cette négociation se poursuit en ce
moment même et nous allons tout faire
évidemment pour obtenir un accord à la
date du 15 novembre plusieurs
organisations syndicales je ne vous le
cache pas nous ont demandé d'aller
encore au delà de cette date
mais aller au delà de cette date cela
signifie retarder encore la mise en
place d'un statut unifié pour l'ensemble
des personnels de france télévisions est
donc de trouver les gains d'efficacité
lié à un régime de travail commun une
organisation du temps de travail commun
et je dirais des positionnements en
termes de classification commun qui
aujourd'hui nous facilite évidemment pas
le travail des équipes
donc nous avons fixé 7
avec encore une fois par voie d'un
accord avec trois des quatre
organisations syndicales nous avons fixé
cette échéance du 15 novembre
pour ce qui concerne les personnels
techniques administratifs alors il
restera un certain nombre de points liés
à certaines mesures concernant le temps
de travail est liée à l'exécution du
contrat de travail mais qui sont des
points de notre point de vue moins
essentielle pour lesquelles nous avons
fixé comme terme la fin de la fin de
cette année donc voilà voilà voilà où on
en est je rappelle que nous avons signé
pour ce qui concerne les journalistes en
accord au mois de septembre de l'année
dernière qui traite l'essentiel de cette
question concernant les journalistes
puisque cet accord traite des principes
professionnels des classifications et
des rémunérations des journalistes et
même des modalités de suivi de la
question des rémunérations pour ce qui
concerne les journalistes ont pour les
journalistes l'essentiel est fait pour
les personnels techniques administratifs
et bien nous allons tout faire pour
avoir un accord d'ici le 15 novembre
mais là évidemment ça ne dépend pas que
de nous c'est c'est un dialogue qui est
très dense je peux vous dire que c'est
plusieurs journées de négociations par
semaine je ne préjuge pas du résultat on
va tout faire en tout cas pour eux pour
aboutir
concernant l'audience dé sur les 4 14
ans deux choses d'abord je le rappelle
nous sommes est de très loin le premier
financeur de l'animation en france
inquiète une industrie qui est une
industrie d'ailleurs qui se porte bien
en france puisqu'on a des des
entreprises et les studios qui sont tout
à fait performant
aujourd'hui nous avons une répartition
sur l'ensemble de nos antennes de
dessins animés qui ont des audiences
d'ailleurs divers suivant les périodes
et suivant les chaînes le projet d'une
offre spécifique pour enfants est un
projet qui reste évidemment au coeur de
nos préoccupations
avec simplement je le redis ici une
première étape qui est de savoir ce que
nous faisons de notre participation dans
gulli
que nous avons 34 % et où aujourd'hui un
pacte d'actionnaires nous contraint si
nous voulons faire autre chose à sortir
et la discussion avec l'autre
actionnaire le groupe lagardère n'est
pas aisé pour le moment la deuxième
chose c'est la réflexion que nous avons
amené dans le très court terme sur
l'offre numérique pour les enfants
nous avons nous sommes en train de
basculer dans un monde du numérique et
nous venons de développer une
application sur les écrans connectés qui
s'appelle ouzou on a une offre pour les
enfants sur les télévisions connectées
est ce que notre offre ne doit pas être
une offre qui se construit dans
l'univers du numérique et notamment des
télévisions connectées plutôt que d'être
sur une offre tnt c'est une question en
tout cas qu'il faut que nous posions à
partir du moment où on voit qu'un
comportement des enfants est en train de
basculer de façon absolument
considérable mais oui nous souhaitons
poursuivre cette réflexion et ce travail
en direction des enfants parce que nous
souhaitons garder notre rôle de
financeur de l'animation française
alors concernant la publicité pour les
trois prochaines années nous avons eu
hier un conseil d'administration de la
régie publicitaire
ce conseil d'admistration nous a dit que
d'abord l'atterrissage autour de - 50 5
millions d'euros que j'avais indiqué il
ya quelques semaines pour 2012 se
concrétisait
sous réserve que les annulations qu'on
enregistre actuellement chez nous comme
dans les autres médias et comme dans les
autres chaînes de télévision ne
s'accélère pas sur les dernières
semaines de l'année pour 2013
aujourd'hui toutes les prévisions sont
des prévisions qui tablent sur une
dégradation par rapport à 2012 ce qui
veut dire que par rapport au contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens là où nous
serons probablement à -55 cette année
nous serons très certainement plus tôt à
moins 70 l'année prochaine c'est des
instituts de conjoncture d'ailleurs ont
dégradé les prévisions trois fois au
cours des sept dernières semaines
il ya donc une anticipation des dépenses
publicitaires qui est mauvaise pour
france télévisions mais au delà de
france télévisions pour tous les médias
français ce qui est une vraie
préoccupation pour notre commission j'en
suis persuadé parce que ça va toucher
tous les médias et de la presse écrite à
la radio et à la télévision
alors c'est un élément évidemment clé de
notre situation parce que à la fin un
manque d'eau manque de ressources
publiques
s'ajoute le la question du financement
par là dans la publicité et donc tout
cela se ce cumul
je t'ai demandé à martin jarrie de faire
un point peut-être rapide pour rappeler
les éléments de la budgétaires liées à
cela sur quelques chiffres par rapport à
ceux qui ont été évoqués effectivement
dans le golfe du projet loi de finances
prévoit 2 euros d'indexation et 2 euros
de complément qui ont été présentés
d'ailleurs à l'assemblée comme étant
deux euros au bénéfice de france
télévisions en fait le projet loi de
finances dans son économie avec de la
redevance indexée est un complément de 2
et une diminution très forte de la
subvention se traduit par le fait que
france télévisions à -3 4% de ressources
publiques par rapport à 2012 au budget
alors que les autres sociétés de
l'audiovisuel public sont à -0 5 - 0 3 à
peu près en stabilité
tout ceci pour dire que 2 euros de
complément serve éventuellement à
diminuer la subvention budgétaire ou
à atténuer l'effet sur nous nos
consoeurs mais en aucun cas on ne peut
dire qu'il bénéficie à france
télévisions le second point que je
voulais et éventuellement précisé qu'on
a on a bien une diminution de 86
millions d'euros c'est moins 3 24%
c'est ce sont les chiffres en tout cas
du prajou la finance alors ce sont les
équilibres entre sociétés il se trouve
que france télévisions et celle de des
sociétés qui en faisant la somme de la
subvention budgétaire et de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public et
celles dont la situation est
objectivement la plus dégradée alors
même qu'elle est exposée par ailleurs à
une conjoncture publicitaire qui s'est
très fortement retourné depuis
depuis depuis six depuis six mois ou
huit mois je me permets cette précision
car vous on est tous conscient qu'on
doit faire des efforts lorsqu'on parle
de 2013 ce double effet de diminution
des ressources publiques et d'exposition
à la conjoncture publicitaire nous
conduit à peu près 200 millions d'euros
en dessous des ressources que le com
prévoyait le président de france
télévisions a évoqué une perte de 81
millions 80 à 100 millions d'euros ce
qui veut dire que d'ores et déjà nous
nous mettons dans une situation où nous
allons faire 100 millions d'euros
d'économies par rapport aux comme ce que
nous disons c'est que les efforts pour
faire ces 100 millions d'euros
d'économies qui sont un perspective
d'ajustement extrêmement forte à un
terme aussi courts sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à réaliser
si la situation financière de
l'entreprise est fragilisé par un niveau
de pertes excessif pour effectivement
rejoindre ce que ce que ce que vous
disiez monsieur le rapporteur
voilà mais c'est je dirais la perte de
80 ou 100 millions d'euros que nous
prévoyons pour 2013 c'est une prévision
elle inclut déjà un effort d'ajustement
extrêmement fort par rapport à ce que le
code et les missions qu'ils contenaient
nous conduisait à prévoir il y a à peine
moins d'un an et et on a évidemment des
salariés permanents nous avons des
contrats de programmes qui sont signés
des oeuvres acquises souvent un deux
trois ans avant leur diffusion donc nous
sommes aussi tenus par ses engagements
juridique et la capacité à s'ajuster en
un délai aussi court et très contrainte
merci pour ces réponses nous allons
passer aux questions cribles je vais
demander à mes collègues d'être concis
ils sont nombreux et je vous rappelle
que nous avons des travaux de la
commission qui doivent se faire aussi ce
matin donc monsieur reynou oui je me
suis le président les salariés du groupe
france télévisions mots saisis
suite aux annonces couleur est fait sur
le projet info 2015 et qui prévoit le
rapprochement des rédactions de france 2
france 3 france info tv cela risque
d'avoir des conséquences sur le maillage
territorial des réactions et sur
l'avenir des enfants qui sont attachés
je sais que cela a déjà été dit que la
situation économique de votre groupe est
délicate suite suppression des recettes
la publicité et le sort est certaine et
accès appelé à compenser ce manque et je
sais que le gouvernement actuel reçoit
en héritage ce qu'il n'a jamais voulu
c'est à dire la fragilisation du service
public audiovisuel
mais aussi que l'information de
proximité est l'une de nos richesses et
que france 3 et ses antennes régionales
participent à la mise en valeur de nos
territoires des initiatives locales et
que les habitants de nos départements
ils sont très attachés
je souhaite donc vous poser trois
questions la première porte sur les
éditions locales et la fermeture et les
fermetures périodiques
à titre d'exemple à ceux qui concerne
mon département le département de l'aude
je sais que cela se fait ailleurs les
audois ne peuvent pas obtenir de
décrochage local pendant 15 jours sur la
période de la toussaint à noël
qu'est ce jour pour la toussaint
quelques jours pour l'un des photos de
remplacement des salariés en congés pour
faire face à cela
vous intégrez les éditions locales au
journal régional au sein du journal
régional unique et diffusé sur
l'ensemble du territoire
de l'antenne régionale dont en réalité
vous fait comblé cette période par des
émissions fabriqués à ecully dont le
contenu sera constitué de sujets
intéressants souvent notre région
la couverture d'informations locales au
sein de notre périmètre géographique
sera donc très réduite
je souhaite vous demander si ces
fermetures saisonnières et des contenus
fabriqués ailleurs sont le signe de la
disparition programmée de ces antennes
locales ou si vous engagez ou si vous
vous engagez à ne pas remettre en cause
de l'information locale et par là
l'identité de votre grand-père sur
l'organisation de prendre sa télévision
ma question est simple avez vous fait un
audit sur le fonctionnement de la
structure
avant de remettre en question les moyens
humains qui fabrique les missions tous
les jours sur le terrain
en fait sur la grille il ya quelques
temps j'ai reçu la plaquette de
communication de votre groupe portant
sur un prévisionnel du dernier trimestre
croît 2012 pour le sud et pour le sud
ouest
je suis inquiet de voir que la seule
contribution des antennes régionales
porte sur l'émission météo qu'il y à de
nombreux créneaux qu'il ya de nombreux
créneaux régionaux au sens très large du
terme sur lequel france 3 diffuse peu de
nouvelles productions où il ya beaucoup
de rediffusions et où la part des
émissions sont faites par le privé ou
pour la filière production en
élargissant le périmètre de diffusion en
acceptant que soient diffusés sur les
antennes régionales des émissions
généralistes 5 caractère local c'est la
présentation de ces la présentation d'un
territoire ces initiatives qui
disparaissent et au delà la perte
d'activité de fabrication des antennes
aussi je souhaite savoir si france 3 et
vous à devenir une chaîne généraliste
avec quelques programmes en région et un
peu d'informations locales régionales ou
si vous aussi vous envisagé de renforcer
son identité comme étant la chaîne des
régions et le relais de la vie locale
des départements en
région ce fut un long exposé avec de
nombreuses questions je vous remercie
il va falloir qu'on soit un peu plus
resserrée dans nos propos madame morin
desailly
à travers la présentation qui nous a été
faite de l'exécution du com dont je
voulais féliciter donc france
télévisions on voit bien que les
missions sont remplies et surtout qu'on
était prise en compte les remarques que
nous avions formulées dans un rapport au
nombre d'autres commissions en 2010 un
rapport effectué avec la commission des
finances je pense à des chantiers tels
que notamment le le global média que
l'on voit vraiment bien mis sur les
rajouts et jusqu'où centre et mon propos
sur les questions le financière et
m'inscrire dans le rush est justement ce
que ce rapport de 2010 avait dit avant
tout préserver france télévisions des
atermoiements et des revirements qui
avait affecté l'entreprise dont les
années précédentes c'est pas moi qui
l'aï dit c'était là la cour des comptes
à l'époque donc je pense qu'il faut plus
que jamais poursuivre le cap et mettre
en oeuvre les grands chantiers d'autant
que la révolution numérique et les
mutations technologiques se sont encore
accélérées depuis le moment où nous
avons voté la loi donc on est dans un
contexte extrêmement concurrentiel
mon regret c'est que nous n'ayons pas
conforter des ressources publiques tel
que nous l'avions dit en 2010 parce que
si nous les avions conforter à l'époque
serait fait boule de neige et on serait
dans une situation aujourd'hui qui
serait moins problématique quand je dis
conforter les ressources publiques c'est
bien sûr la redevance ou la contribution
à l'audiovisuel public à travers
plusieurs mesures chacun sait que nous
avions proposée en loi de finances 2011
et 2012 est malheureusement elles n'ont
pas été votées mais d'un côté comme de
l'autre je crois que c'est une
responsabilité collective
alors je crois qu'il va falloir
dans le cadre de cette loi de finances
prendre nos responsabilités par rapport
à l'eau le confort apporté à ces
ressources publiques je pense notamment
à l'extension aussi de la redondance à
tous les terminaux informatiques par
mesure de neutralité technologique soit
on ne va pas reparler mais ça me semble
important de revenir là dessus
et puis faire en sorte que cette fameuse
augmentation france télévisions puisse
quand même en obtenir tout partiellement
bénéfices parce que c'est aussi une
source de motivation je pense pour
l'entreprise dans sa réalisation
parallèlement d'économie des économies
on l'a dit il est nécessaire que chacun
en fasse un vu l'état de la crise et du
déficit des finances publiques mais je
crois que l'entreprise en est consciente
ma question est donc la suivante
cet effort de 150 millions d'appareils
pour le moins brutale compte tenu des
chantiers à accomplir qu'est ce que l'on
peut imaginer comme plan d'étalement de
ces économies de manière à ce que
concomitamment si on imagine que vous
êtes conforté en matière de ressources
publiques en matière d'attribution de
l'affectation de la redevance
qu'est ce qu'on peut imaginer comme plan
de résorption d'économies voilà ma
question est très simple même brigitte
gonthier maurin
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le président on peut évidemment que
partager votre inquiétude
al'annonce de l'ampleur du plan
d'économies requis financement public de
france télévisions
parce qu'évidemment réduction des moyens
financiers systématiquement dire
réduction du périmètre des missions
donc moi j'ajoute une pointe de colère
mais j'ai cru comprendre que vos propos
était aussi un petit peu empreint de de
colère et on sait ce que ça veut dire
quand on parle de réduction des moyens
et des périmètres en termes de service
public de l'audiovisuel
parce qu'au fond c'est une question
fondamentale de démocratie qui nous est
posée et on sait que ça veut dire moins
d'informations - d'accès à la culture et
moins de citoyenneté donc c'est une
question grave
et je veux dire après d'autre que de mon
point de vue la situation dramatique
dans laquelle se trouve l'entreprise ne
relève pas du hasard bien sûr il ya une
conjoncture qui est défavorable je ne la
nie pas mais les difficultés que nous
rencontrons sont aussi largement dû à la
loi de 2009 que nous avons que nous
avons n'avons pas décidé d'approuver
donc moi j'ai ma question est assez
simple parce que je n'ai pas entendu
dans vos propos j'ai entendu ce qu'avait
dit david assouline sur la proposition
d'augmenter de deux euros
supplémentaires la redevance mais
fondamentalement est-ce que vous avez
réfléchi à des pistes nouvelles de
financement pour asseoir une pérennité
du service public de l'audiovisuel
moi j'ai des propositions on avait des
propositions à vous faire est ce que par
exemple on s'est donné la peine
d'examiner la capacité pour france
télécom de détenir des droits d'auteurs
locaux
ce que j'ai dit - des formations
professionnelles mais bon tous les
services publics je vous fais pas de
dessin
voilà l'augmentation de la redevance ça
a été ça a été abordé mais on a aussi
évoqué la possibilité d'une redevance ou
d'une taxe google sur ces aspects là
est-ce que vous avez exploré des pistes
nouvelles
de financement et peut-être qu'il faut
remettre sur le tapis la question de la
publicité
monsieur plancade
merci madame le président merci monsieur
le président on a écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention votre exposé et bien sûr
depuis quelques temps où on partage tout
vos craintes
jeudi j'ai pas spécialement de questions
opposé mais j'ai une remarque générale
que je fais chaque fois que j'en ai
l'occasion ici on peut pas dans une
démocratie on ne peut pas vouloir
assurer l'indépendance d'un service
public de télévision de l'audiovisuel et
en même temps le soumettre à un vote du
parlement
ça c'est une contradiction absolue il
faut trouver un autre système pour le
rendre indépendant alors on fait du bric
et de broc 2 euros on va voter deux
euros de plus et très bien tant mieux si
on nous avait écouté ce que disait tout
à l'heure
ma collègue catherine morin desailly
c'est vrai qu' on aurait pu on aurait
moins de pertes mais le problème de fond
c'est celui de remettre en cause ce
service public pour lui assurer une
pérennité de fond et qu'ils soient
simplement liée à un financement
autonome et ce financement autonome il
ne peut arriver que par la télé villars
la redevance le prix de cette liberté
pour chacun de nos concitoyens
c'est un peu moins de 3 euros par mois
un peu moins de 3 euros par mois voilà
le prix de cette liberté
alors ensuite bon il ya les résidents
secondaires y avons tout ce qui a été
évoqué mais le principe général c'est
celui là
la deuxième la deuxième remarque je
voulais faire c'est que je suis étonné
que dans le service public encore qu'ils
ne soient pas on ne puisse pas
constituer une bibliothèque d'oeuvres
dont il est finalement le propriétaire
parce que la plupart des cas dans la
plupart des cas c'est lui qui les a
financés qui les diffuse qui en assurent
le succès et ils appartiennent à
d'autres donc il faut que ces droits
d'auteur et cette propriété reste au
service public pour qu'elle puisse tirer
de là des revenus supplémentaires
voilà ce que je tenais à redire ici
devant devant vous monsieur le président
et à mes collègues aussi merci mesdames
blondin
merci madame la présidente je ne reviens
pas sur ce que mon collègue de l'aude a
dit concernant évidemment les les
problèmes que rencontre france 3 en
région et en local beaucoup de craintes
nous avons aidé je crois les uns les
autres sollicité par les les
professionnels par contre je voudrais
moi vous interrogé sur les risques que
cela pourrait entraîner sur les
conventions entre france 3 et des
services de diffusion télévisée sur le
web
il y à des conventions qui existent dans
la région bretagne entre france 3 et des
services de télévision sur le web en
langue régionale en langue régionale et
qui apportent des des programmes axés
sur les enfants sur la genèse et une
première convention vient d'être signée
pour 2013 avec france 3 est ce cette
structure qui s'appelle brezhoweb et sur
la musique classique il ya tout un
programme sur la musique classique
concernant l'année prochaine qu'est ce
qu'il va en advenir en sachant que cette
offre numérique allait bien sûr diffusée
sur les réseaux sociaux est allé de plus
en plus regardées et fréquenté vous avez
évoqué également tout à l'heure france 5
brièvement et un peu parlé de
spécialisation de chaîne france 5 a
développé en lien avec l'éducation
nationale des plateformes culture lycée
ciné lycée etc et aussi des outils à
destination des enseignants et des
parents d'élèves
je pense que nous aurions et vous auriez
évidemment tout à votre honneur
l'intérêt de développer les relations
avec l'éducation nationale et de faire
en sorte que cette chaîne soit peut-être
spécialisé dans des programmes jeunesse
pourquoi pas éducation jeunesse et et
plus largement autour autour de ces
ressources qui existent et qui pourrait
être un moyen de de diffusion spécifique
pour la jeunesse voilà merci merci
monsieur chiron oui madame la présidente
monsieur le président beaucoup de choses
ont été dites et je m'inscrirai dans ce
qui a été dit par mes collègues
particulièrement par mon collègue david
assouline je crois qu'il ya bien qui a
bien mille le fait de ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières années quel en est le
résultat est juste il ne s'agit pas du
tout pour nous d'avoir comme on l'a dit
une responsabilité collective la
responsabilité elle a été en amont et
aujourd'hui il faut trouver une solution
je voudrais tout temps tout en reprenant
l'idée de mes collègues sur les droits
d'auteur moi je voudrais connaître quel
est le coût du tunnel publicitaire entre
20h30 mettons et 20h40 ou à kurt 30 35
j'ai bien entendu que vous aviez dit
enfin il avait été dit précédée il y à
un certain nombre de temps que la
publicité autour de 20 heures c'est
celle qui entre guillemets rapporté le
plus en coups en résulte alors je sais
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une conjoncture qui
est négative mais il faut s'inscrire
dans le temps il faut pas s'inscrire
uniquement dans la conjoncture actuelle
et moi je me pose la question j'ai envie
de dire comme il a été dit sur un petit
livret qu'on a sûrement tous reçu ce
sans tabou qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que
coûte qu'est ce que rapporterait à
france télévisions une réouverture de la
publicité puisque même ma collègue l'a
dit
tout à l'heure entre 20h30 et 20h40
merci monsieur le scouarnec
l'inla brésil semaine dans la prison
l'essentiel a été dit donc je partage
les soucis que tu es exprimer les
inquiétudes je pense que le tableau est
noir
j'ai des craintes pour l'avenir de
france télévision et je souhaite que la
qualité soit maintenue on ne peut pas se
contenter de rediffusions qui
remplaceraient des créations de ces
rares genre aurait d'ailleurs de baisse
d'audience et baisse de recettes
publicitaires également dans le nous
continuerions à voir les problèmes
demain cela aujourd'hui on ne règlerait
pas les problèmes financiers donc je
souhaite qu'on arrive à trouver des
ressources pérennes alors c'est soit des
nouvelles taxes soit en augmentant
nettement la redevance mais en tout cas
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'un qu'une
entreprise de france télévisions soit
obligé de bricoler chaque année pour
colmater des manques de ressources qui
seraient pas rentrer parce qu'il y avait
la publicité qui est en baisse un peu
opère sa grande millions ou 20 millions
et est à nouveau ça remet tout travail
en cause
je souhaite que les uns et les autres
nous apportions des les propositions et
qu'au final vous soyez dans la sérénité
pour nous apporter programme de qualité
comme vous l'avez fait par le passé
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je serais très
triste que demain et après demain nous
ayons une france télévisions dégradé et
avec un public très déçu et ce sera
recul culturel je ne souhaite pas merci
monsieur guerlain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président nous avons suivi avec
attention votre premier état de
l'établissement du comme j'ai lu le
document dans son entièreté je dois dire
que si les conditions qui ont été
maintes fois rappelé par la présidente
de la commission de d'études par le
parlement et notamment par le sénat de
ceux comme avait puisse faire je pense
qu'il ya un certain nombre de choses en
amont qu'on aurait pu discuter je le dis
parce que il ya beaucoup d'éléments je
vois qu'on insiste beaucoup sur la
maîtrise des coûts on assiste sur la
maîtrise des coûts internes de
production des coûts externes hors
programme dense comme à l'exception de
la page 57 on parle très peu de la
maîtrise des coûts
concernant les achats auprès des
producteurs indépendants et des
producteurs extérieurs
il y a quand même est néanmoins certain
nombre de d'objectifs qui ont été fixés
celle d'établir tout non tous les deux
villes et poste de rémunération du
producteur sont clairement identifiés je
cite page 57 suivi une base de données
devaient être faites moi je m'étonne
pour connaître assez bien le milieu de
la télévision et y avoir travaillé
aujourd'hui un grand nombre de
producteurs qui officie pour france
télévisions sont des sociétés privées
qui elle-même appartiennent à des
holdings international qui effectuent
des marges déjà en amont groupe et des
marges sociétés nationales très
importante
on parle de marges parfois de l'ordre de
40% du prix d émission
je pense que là il ya une école
questionnement est une matière
effectivement il faut trouver des
nouvelles ressources pour la télévision
mais je pense que il ya des mesures
d'économie parce qu'on travaille avec
des sociétés outre comme l'a rappelé mon
collègue plancade on ne possède aucun
droit de propriété donc on est les
produits dérivés la revente des concepts
des émissions ou des fictions fait
partie pleinement des ressources
aujourd'hui d'une chaîne il n'y a pas
que la redevance et la publicité pour
financer autre objet que je trouve très
faible dans les objectifs qui avaient
été fixés par le code c'est la
définition des objectifs de public
d'audience alors heureusement
le com ne fixe pas un objectif
d'audience pour l'ensemble de france
télévisions ce qui est proprement
impossible il ya quelques petites
allusions au fait que quand même france
télévisions doit couvrir tous les
publics
et force est de constater que l'audience
globale de france télévisions quand même
a souffert ces dernières années elle a
souffert principalement sur deux cibles
grand public ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs
par ailleurs dans les milieux
publicitaire l'audience marchande c'est
à dire les populations féminines et
masculines de 25 à 59 ans et la
traditionnelle ménagère de moins de 50
ans alors je le dis parce que j'ai le
sentiment que france télévisions dans
ses objectifs
oui ménagères de moins de cinquante ans
oui les jeux je dis cela parce que j'ai
le sentiment que l'audience de
télévision s'est renforcé sur les
publics âgés conserve des bases sur les
publics enfants mais que ont failli à
notre mission de parler à tout le monde
et nos temps plus si on doit envisager
demain retour de la publicité
on ne reviendra pas à périmètre constant
parce que les sites de population celle
que j'ai cités qui sont les plus
recherchées par le marché publicitaire
ont été durement affectés
là encore je ne vois pas dans les bilans
qui sont faits d' analyse autre que
globale de l'audience vous nous avez
parlé des très bonnes performances de
france 24 sur les jeunes actifs j'en
suis ravi mais au global consolidé de
l'ensemble du groupe france télévisions
je suis pas certain que les équilibres
en terme de public des performances
aujourd'hui de france télévisions soit
satisfaisant et soit sur une bonne
évolution
enfin les derniers éléments puisque on
parle d'eux
révision de ce code est notamment d'un
nouvel objectif de 500 départs
volontaires je rappelle que le précédent
plan qui engageait 900 départs
volontaires n'est toujours pas bouclé
donc j'aimerais savoir comment vous
entendez vous y prendre pour faire 500
départs volontaires sans plan social sec
dans la logique que vous avez notamment
présenté à la presse ou aux syndicats de
france télévisions chevron merci merci
monsieur gâteux là monsieur lui merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
président je vais essayer d'être le plus
bref possible en sortant si c'est
possible de d'un esprit un peu
schizophrénique entre ma fonction
d'administrateur de france télévisions
où je représente au fond globalement
l'institution et ma perception
personnelle sur le sujet et parfois un
peu quelques écarts je voudrais
simplement en tant qu'administrateur
apporter le témoignage des efforts qui
sont faits par l'équipe depuis déjà de
nombreuses années pour prendre en compte
la situation financière globale et les
efforts d'économie de réduction des
changes pour se remettre dans un sillage
on va dire normal je me pose également
la question du contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens en m'interrogeant sur le nombre
d'heures de travail d'audition le nombre
de rames de papier de réunion de
rencontre pour un come-back contrat
d'objectifs et de brive qui vole en
éclats en quelques secondes à la suite
d'une crise que tout le monde reconnaît
mais c'est vraiment sa porte
interrogations je suis un peu comme le
président de france télévision je me dis
voilà on traverse une période difficile
d'un mâle peut et doit sortir un bien et
d'un handicap il faut essayer de faire
un atout plutôt que allait faire tirer à
haro sur le baudet sur la loi de 2009
je pense que la cause c'est quand même
aussi un certain nombre de demi mesures
qui n'ont pas forcément permis d'aller
au bout de la réforme donc sans prendre
de position immédiate je pense vraiment
qu'il faut relancer une vraie réflexion
sur les dépenses bien sûr et et sur les
recettes et sur leurs 7 va se reposer la
question globale de la publicité va se
reposer la question globale de la
redevance et de la contribution de
visuel public
je pense qu'on est en plein de mesures
dans les deux sujets soit mais on peut
les deux sont pliables et je pense
qu'aucune position doctrinale ne doit
primer sur un essai d'intelligence
collective soit on dit que la publicité
n'est pas un élément de différenciation
global entre le secteur public et le
secteur privé
l on y va à fond et on met la régir en
ligne et on essaie d'être meilleur que
le privé et onu on n'est pas d'ailleurs
mauvais et mais enfin voilà à titre
personnel je pense que c'est un élément
de différence de différenciation
considérable c'est à dire enfin c'est
mon avis personnel c'est que le service
public de télévision peut se
différencier vraiment s'il n'a plus du
tout aucune aucune charge publicitaires
mais il n'y a pas de demi-mesure après
20 heures 20 heures et puis alors
l'histoire des parrainages qui ont comme
un trouble est considérablement l'homme
zur voilà on a fait une demi mesure
quant à la redevance pour nos demandes
de 2,2 euros + 2 euros c'est encore une
mesure
voilà qui essayent de compléter la
demi-mesure de l'autre donc moi je crois
qu'une vraie réflexion va s'engager sans
duo français votre télévision coûte ça
et on fait comme les autres pays
d'europe et on change l'assiette et le
taux ou l'un ou l'autre ou les deux de
la contribution à l'audiovisuel public
puisque nous sommes globalement un des
plus bas d'europe
je sais que circonstances de la crise
rend la chose très difficile en termes
de perception par les ménagères et les
ménages et par les ménages mais jeudi
les ménagères et les ménages et je suis
politiquement correct mais si les trier
pas vos collègues
voilà donc moi je ne me positionne pas
parce que je pense qu'un vrai débat de
fond le sénat c'est toujours honoré
d'essayer d'être en phase global de ne
pas mener des combats de doctrinaux sur
ces sujets mais les deux pivots c'est
bien ça la pub et la redevance alors il
faut vraiment qu'on mette tout sur la
table
moi je serais partisan meilleur c'est
personnel je pense que la redevance est
faible que je regrette peut-être un
titre personnel font encore que on n'est
pas soutenue l'extension l'élargissement
de l'assiette aux résidents secondaires
et puis on ne s'épargnera pas exempt
finit là on ne sait par les rapa le
débat sur la fiscalisation des écrans
salaire que dans un an ou deux ans
peut-être 3
il n'y aura plus tôt il n'y aura plus
que des ordinateurs connectés d'evra et
donc on va se retrouver finalement
avec presque un réduction de sydney que
les téléviseurs
on dirait qu'ils sont fiscalisées donc
on s'épargnera pas ça je pense qu'un
petit groupe peut repartir dans le cadre
de la préparation de ce que j'ai cru
comprendre être une nouvelle loi sur
l'audiovisuel à venir en 2013
merci messieurs même si le gendre oui
même la présidente
mes chers collègues j'ai de la chance de
parler le dernier parce que je peux
ainsi dire que dans ce débat je crois
que des paroles sages ont été prononcées
par ma collègue m'a morin desailly et
par mon collègue monsieur le nous avons
eu entre autres
nous avons eu dans le passé un débat qui
portait sur la suppression de la
publicité
faut pas le dire que c'est arrivé comme
ça la critique sur l'audimat elle
existait depuis longtemps est une
réponse à la au problème de l'excès de
référence à l'audimat c'était bien de se
poser la question de la publicité
bon ce qui était difficile à prévoir
c'était l'effet exact de cette
suppression je rappelle qu'à l'époque on
nous a quand même dit que c'était pour
faire plaisir aux chaînes
publ privé et on se rend compte
maintenant que les faits en a été tout à
fait différent nous sommes un certain
nombre aussi à penser que d'un point de
vue culturel
c'était pas négatif du tout que de
pouvoir faire disparaître la publicité
et de distinguer le service privé les
chaînes privées des chaînes publiques en
faisant en sorte que les chaînes
publiques ne soit plus sous l'emprise
directe de l'audimat
même si on s'en est bien rendu compte
dans nos travaux monsieur a souligné
mois après on se rend compte que
l'audimat il est dans les têtes qu'il
continue à peser et quand même quand il
ya moins ou plus de deux redevances de
publicité et bien il imprègne encore les
comportements donc tout ça ça s'inscrit
dans le temps ce que je comprends pas
très bien c'est qu'on nous dise on vous
l'avait bien dit les finances de france
télévisions al être mise en péril est en
difficulté et que l'effort dont vous
nous rend des comptes et qui vous est
imposée ou qui risquent de vous être
imposées monsieur le président
apparaissent trop brutale par rapport à
la situation
parce que ce que l'on sait aussi c'est
que organiser la réorganisation la
réorganisation de l'ensemble du
dispositif france télévisions ça prend
du temps et que les bénéfices d'une
certaine mutualisation se feront
progressivement alors que les faits qui
vous frappe
il est immédiat et à un moment où vous
n'êtes sans doute pas en état de dégager
les économies qui permettrait de gager
l'effort qui vous est demandé alors moi
je crois aussi comme madame morin
desailly que ce qu'il serait intéressant
de voir c'est qu'elle est fort peut vous
être raisonnablement demander maintenant
sachant qu'il ne peut être que
progressif et accompagner les
économie que votre que france
télévisions doit incontestablement
obtenir tirer de cette réorganisation
voilà après ça nous aurons effectivement
le problème du financement de
l'audiovisuel public
il ya une culture de cette commission
qui n'est pas la culture de l'ensemble
du sénat on l'a bien vu mais nous
l'avons portée et on a eu le courage de
faire en sorte en particulier lors d'une
cmp qui fut épique que le problème de
l'augmentation de la redevance soit pris
en compte y compris au moment de la
discussion de la loi
je pense que nous sommes nombreux ici à
nous interroger sur ce que doit être
l'effort demandé aux téléspectateurs
consommateurs pour avoir un service
public de qualité et ça nous l'avons
portée majorité et opposition du passé
comme de maintenant alors essayons de
nous concentrer sur ses problèmes là
pour trouver des réponses justes et puis
après tout puisque on dit qu'une
nouvelle loi est en préparation sur
l'audiovisuel et bien on verra ce que la
nouvelle majorité va pouvoir nous
proposer
en tout cas nous ne vous n'entendons pas
reculer sur l'exigence de qualité le
calima plutôt que l'audimat ça on ne
cessera pas de le répéter
et puis je crois qu'il faut plus que
jamais que nous soyons réalistes et à la
fois pressent dans les efforts qu'on
vous demande mais en même temps en
sachant qu'on ne peut pas vous demander
des efforts qui compromettrait notre
objectif de qualité du service public
merci monsieur legendre
j'en reviens au sujet qui nous
rassemblait qui était quand même
l'exécution du comme dans l'exécution du
comme il ya deux indicateurs le 3 1 3
qui évoquait une enquête d'évaluation de
la santé au travail et le 3/4 un
baromètre de cohésion sociale avant fans
donc je voudrais savoir où en sont
ces deux indicateurs et d'autre part
monsieur primes là vous avez évoqué la
nécessité de faire connaître mieux
france télévisions par rapport à toute
la concurrence
une simple remarque féminine
n'allez pas trop loin dans l'humour dans
la publicité
nous avons bien noté les panneaux qui
disait que vous montriez des chiennes à
la télévision je sais le génie créateur
des publicistes mais ne descendez pas
trop bas afin que vous répondiez
monsieur film là monsieur assouline
souhaitait apporter une précision sur
ses propos oui il peut ya pu y avoir une
confusion sur un élément précis donc que
je rappelle il y a
ce qui sort du vote de l'assemblée
nationale en recettes plus 4 euros + 2 +
2 ce qui fait que vous seriez dans
quelque chose à moins 86 millions dans
la notation publique
je répète donc que je proposerai ici que
nous augmentions caen 2 2 euros pour que
l'effort qui vous soit demandée soit de
30 millions ce qui diminue nettement ce
que vous allez dire qui va dans le sens
tout ce qui a été défendue ici qu'il y
aller fort mais pas d'effort trop brutal
et immédiat qui déstabilisent ensemble
de l'audiovisuel voilà vous savez la
parole monsieur rémy puis si même la
présidente
je dois être commencer par vos questions
précises et puis après un très ponctuel
peut-être d'abord patrice papet sur
santé au travail et baromètre cohésion
sociale ou alors le barreau mada
cohésion sociale il a été réalisé pour
une première fois il ya environ un an et
demi
c'est d'ailleurs
des résultats de cette enquête nous ont
conduit à élaborer un plan de route
parce que une les enseignements de cette
enquête qui a été réalisée c'était que
les collaborateurs de france télévisions
avait trouvé que la la stratégie est un
peu loin de leurs préoccupations et donc
nous sommes efforcés la suite de ce
baromètre de mettre en place un neuf
chantiers très concrets et dans lesquels
il était impliqué ou concernés pour la
plupart nous allons nous allons puisque
c'est un baromètre c'est une mesure
régulière
nous allons dans quelques mois au
premier semestre de l'année prochaine
réaliser un nouveau baromètre est une
nouvelle mesure de cohésion sociale sur
l' enquête santé au travail là on est en
train de la préparer et il est prévu de
la faire à la fin de cette année mais
entre temps on est mis en place un
tableau de bord qui nous permet de
suivre les questions notamment de santé
d'absentéisme et de sécurité au travail
donc qui construit avec attention
et d'ailleurs les tendances actuelles
sont plutôt en amélioration mais une
amélioration qui reste très légère et
très fragile après les difficultés qu'on
avait rencontré en matière de santé
d'absentéisme notamment suite à la
fusion de 2010 voilà ce tableau de bord
existe l'enquète elle va être réalisée
auprès de l'ensemble des salariés dans
un mois et demi à peu près sur la
question de la publicité oui nous
faisons des campagnes de publicité mais
en l'occurrence c'était pour nous
différencier des chaînes privées en
disant précisément que coton quand on
adresse
quand on s'adresse à nos publics on ne
parle pas de la même chose que les voilà
je vais essayer de répondre à l'ensemble
de vos questions les ans les en les
ramassant le premier point le point
central c'est effectivement et vous
l'avez dit les uns et les autres de bien
déterminer quelles sont nos missions et
ses missions sont des missions que nous
aurons à rediscuter
dans le cas de l'avenant au contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens avec l'état
mais pour moi il y a quatre missions
principales la première c'est la mission
d'information
donc nous continuons à investir sur
l'information a développé les émissions
d'information parce que très clairement
c'est une mission qui permet d'une part
d'avoir une référence dans le débat
démocratique
et puis cette c'est une mission qui va
nous différencier de plus en plus des
chaînes privées qui elles vont
naturellement de plus en plus d investir
sur l'information
et lorsque je parle d'informations ces
informations sous toutes ses formes que
ce soit l'information national ou
international où l'information locale et
de ce point de vue là il n'est pas
question pour nous de 2,2 de baisser la
garde sur les objectifs d'information
locale alors qu'il s'agisse dans le
cadre de nos plans de
de rationalisation d'optimisation de
faire en sorte qu'à un moment donné nous
puissions limiter l'emploi ou non
permanents et donc fermé des locales à
certains moments de l'année pour lisser
l'emploi certes mais lycée l'emploi ça
veut pas dire fermer à terme et surtout
contrairement à ce qui a pu être évoqué
dans le journal régional correspondant à
7 locale il y aura bien des informations
concernant les localités en question et
non pas des informations venant venant
d'ailleurs c'est un engagement que nous
que nous prenons donc un information de
création et création parce que d'abord
c'est un élément clé de la vie d'un pays
que d'avoir une création autonome et que
cette création soit diffusé mais c'est
aussi ce qui va nous différencier de ce
que font les autres télévisions donc
deuxième élément création troisième
élément très fort c'est la présence
territoriale donc le fait non seulement
d'avoir de l'information mais d'être
présents sur le territoire métropolitain
et outre-mer et cette présence et elie
évidemment un élément clé de
différenciation et puis quatrième
objectif central le numérique parce que
le numérique c'est aujourd'hui ce qui
nous permet de mieux faire connaître ce
que nous faisons et le développement des
usages et elle sur l'ensemble des écrans
que le fait d'avoir aujourd'hui une
présence sur tous les écrans
c'est ni plus ni moins que tu adrano
objectif qui est de faire partager au
plus grand nombre des informations de
référence et de la haie et de la
création
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça mais cette
question là une question éminemment
politique qui évidemment vous appartient
appartient la à leur représentation
nationale comme vient de le faire c'est
vous qui devez au niveau du parlement
porter ce besoin qu'a le pays la nation
de ces éléments là après il nous faut
évidemment des moyens pour atteindre ses
objectifs ses moyens c'est la première
des choses que je voudrais vraiment sur
laquelle je voudrais insister ses moyens
ils doivent être pérennes
parce que vous voyez bien que la grande
difficulté dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est les allées venues incessants on ne
peut pas négocier pendant un an un
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens le
signer en novembre atteindre les
missions que nous avons fixés et je
viens d'où viens de vous le montrer et
se retrouver moins d'un an après dans le
toit plat on recommence aucune
organisation ne peut vivre cela aucune
entreprise aucune organisation
il faut qu'on puisse se situer dans la
dans la dans la dans la pérennité et la
pérennité c'est donc trouver des modes
de financement pérenne alors ses modes
de financement pérenne c'est dans tous
les grands audiovisuel public d'abord la
redevance et cette redevance
moi je rejoins ce que vous avez dit les
uns et les autres
profitons de la loi audiovisuelle qui
arrivent pour dire c'est quoi la
redevance dans ce pays
je vous signale mais vous le savez
probablement que l'allemagne vient de
modifier complètement sa redevance alors
sa redevance en allemagne avec 225 euros
là où chez nous elle est de 125
d'ailleurs je signale que lorsqu'on
demande aux allemands combien payez-vous
de redevances ils vous disent pas de 125
euros et vous 10 18 euros ce qui paye 18
chaque mois et donc les allemands
viennent entièrement de modifier
l'assiette de la redevance et cette
redevance allemande aujourd'hui elle est
fondée sur d'autres choses enfin bon
pour un point
on pourra l'analyser mais en tout cas ce
qui me semble important c'est de
relégitimer de refonder et je crois que
ces sénateurs plancade qui a dit est de
faire en sorte que cette redevance est
puisse être analysées par une autorité
indépendante qui dit à un moment donné
voilà de quoi a besoin ce qu'ils font
les allemands les anglais le niveau de
la redevance en allemagne et en
angleterre
il est approché par des autorités
indépendantes qui le soumettent bien sûr
au parlement mais ce que me disent mes
confrères allemands ou anglais
c'est que de l'histoire de la bbc où
l'histoire de l'ère des bleus zdf jamais
le parlement n'est allé contre parce que
c'était une façon de garantir
l'indépendance
concernant la publicité moi aujourd'hui
ce que je peux dire simplement c'est que
la publicité c'est un élément
aujourd'hui de nos ressources qui peut
créer de la dynamique qui peut nous
permettre un moment donné d'avoir
peut-être ceux plus de ressources qui à
un moment donné permettra de 2,2 de
faire plus de faire mieux d'investir
davantage comme une entreprise qui est
une entreprise qui a des objectifs
commerciaux alors évidemment elle ne
doit pas c'était pervertir nos missions
puisque la mission en première mais elle
doit nous permettre un moment donné
peut-être d'approcher les choses sur le
plan financier économique différent là
aussi il nous faut des règles pérenne et
là ce que je pense et vous l'avez abordé
dans votre question c'est qu'il faut que
en tout cas si nous devions reparler de
la publicité qu'on n'en parle pas comme
dans tout ou rien le débat qui consiste
à ce titre meet et de la publicité et la
réponse qui est non il faut pas en
maître n'est pas la réponse
travaillons sur le sujet est ce que la
publicité
j'ouvre des pistes est ce qu'à certaines
heures sur certaines chaînes on peut en
mettre escale inverse il faut supprimer
complètement la publicité sur certains
programmes ou certaines on peut avoir un
dispositif il faut en débattre
mais la plus mauvaise des solutions
c'est de dire tout ou rien parce que
tout ou rien est évidemment une impasse
aujourd'hui
troisième point que vous avez abordé les
uns les autres c'est notre capacité à
générer des recettes diverses
alors certes est diverse c'est ce que
nous faisons déjà aujourd'hui en
développant la vod c'est à dire
désaccords que nous passons pour vendre
sur le numérique des films des fictions
et on a aujourd'hui sur itunes
des premiers résultats qui sont positifs
et nous avons démarré avec free une
plateforme qui se commence à être
positifs aussi nous devons poursuivre
mais la question clé que vous avez
abordé et profitons de la doit à venir
c'est dans l'univers numérique
quid des droits dans l'univers numérique
comment est-ce que le financement qu'a
apporté france télévisions qu'apportent
les télévisions
à ses oeuvres comment est-ce qu'on
aborde les choses différemment
comment est ce qu'on fait je le dis aux
créateurs français dans l'univers
numérique ou nos concurrents ce sont
google apple ou d'autres allons-y groupe
et les producteurs français chacun de
son côté est mal placé pour avoir des
discussions au niveau où il faut avec
ces acteurs extrêmement important qui
toute façon son sont sur le territoire
donc réfléchissons aussi à cette
question des droits sont en sorte qu'on
puisse peut-être avoir une partie de
patrimoine dans nos comptes sont en
sorte qu'on puisse dynamiser les oeuvres
la vente des oeuvres au profit tout le
monde des auteurs des réalisateurs des
producteurs et de france télévisions
mais en tout cas cette question doit
aussi être posée dans le dans l'univers
dans lequel dans lequel nous arrivons
étant entendu que bien bien sûr il ne
s'agit pas aujourd'hui la non plus de
faire tout rien céder on va pas faire
comme les allemands ou les anglais où
tous les droits appartiennent à la bbc
ou à la r d
mais trouvant quelque chose qui nous
permette aussi de moderniser et et
d'avancer les choses alors sur le lait
des efforts à faire donc je vous le
redis évidemment nous sommes prêts à
faire des efforts et nous devons les
faire et nous les ferons
aujourd'hui nous avons en 2012
des efforts qui sont je voulais dit tout
à l'heure d'un plan de l'ordre de 40
millions d'euros d'économies que nous
allons faire nous pouvons prolonger ce
plan est allé au delà en 2000 en 2012 en
2013 mais mais encore une fois par
rapport aux 200 millions qui manquent en
2013 sur le rapport aux comme si nous
nous rapprochons d'un plan d'économies
200 millions il reste encore 100
millions c'est ça c'est ça le le sujet
central
oui pardon oui mais je réagi très
positivement monsieur le rapporteur
évidemment je réagi très positivement
mais après non je réagis très peu de
jeunes non je suis pas dans la plainte
c'est les choses sont trop sérieuse pour
être dans la plainte mais non bien sûr
j'ai réagi très positivement mais
j'aimerais porter et que si nous
pouvions nous retrouver avec une
dotation non pas moins 86 - mais à moins
on serait dans une situation
incroyablement plus favorable évidemment
évidemment sur les questions de
négociations avec les producteurs
j'ai indiqué alors c'est peut-être pas
dans le dans le rapport du com mais j'ai
indiqué très clairement dans mon exposé
que nous avions commencé à éditer
systématiquement les les émissions de
flux que ça nous avait permis dès la
rentrée de 2011 de fer 7 millions
d'euros d'économies sur la grille de
rentrée
en renégociant la baisse les les
émissions de flux que ces émissions de
flux était systématiquement aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il ya des renouvellements audités
et avec des niveaux de marges qui ne
sont plus celles que vous avez indiqué
monsieur le sénateur mais qui sont
beaucoup plus basses et nous avons
d'ailleurs produit effectué là des
négociations qui sont au coup par coup
et non pas une autre vision qui aurait
pu être de dire on fait moins 10 à tout
le monde mais il ya des ddd producteurs
où on a baissé beaucoup plus que 10 et
d'autres moins avec des audits qui sont
des audits externes suivi extrêmement
précise donc on est parti là dessus
sachant que il faut maintenant que nous
puissions aussi travaillé sur des audits
concernant les oeuvres la création ce
qui n'est pas le cas pour le moment
parce que les syndicats de producteurs
d'oeuvre de
ne le souhaitait pas mais nous allons le
faire de la même façon et je le dis très
clairement des émissions de flux sur
lequel nous ne parvenons pas à négocier
comme nous le souhaitons sont des
émissions que nous remplacerons et et
les un certain nombre de producteurs
importants de la place le savait et et
notamment dans les négociations début de
cette saison l'ont vue concernant les
structures d'audience on est bien là
dans un des paradoxes du service public
où l'on dit ne vous occupez pas
d'audience mais occupent eux vous ont
quand même et votre remarque est juste
parce que lorsque nous disons nous
voulons toucher tous nos concitoyens
c'est pas les toucher en permanence
comme des cibles commerciales
mais c'est d'abord faire en sorte et
c'est une mesure que nous avons que tous
les français fréquentent à un moment ou
un autre des programmes de france
télévisions et on a là des taux de plus
de 80 5% qui sont qu'ils sont
satisfaisants
oui et non si vous avez vous avez
certaines certaines chaînes où ce n'est
pas le cas du tout où il ya des cibles
très précises bon j'ai des éléments là
que je peux vous donner concernant les
cibles alors évidemment je l'indiquais
tout à l'heure france 4 à une croissance
très fort sur les 25 59 ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'en 2012
à ce jour c'est à dire les éléments que
j'ai sous les yeux c'est la semaine 42
c'est-à-dire au 21 octobre donc du 1er
janvier au 21 octobre
sur les 25 59 nous touchons 24 9 % des
25 59
là où nous étions à 24,1 en 2011
donc nous sommes sur un quart alors
cette saison cette hausse des taux
d'audience un taux d'audience moyens ça
veut dire que on en touche beaucoup plus
mais c'est un taux de mou des ans moyens
et vous dire que de ce point de vue là
aujourd'hui sur ces mêmes cibles
tf1 est plutôt en régression et que nous
sommes devant tf1 en pénétration sur
cette cible
à ce jour pourquoi parce que ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui et vous l'avez dit
c'est que globalement l'âge moyen des
gens qui regardent la télévision
augmente et il augmente pour toutes les
chaînes et notamment pour les chaînes
commerciales
ce qui fait d'ailleurs que les cibles
commerciales des grandes chaînes privées
ne sont plus les ménagères de moins de
cinquante ans mais sont plutôt de moins
de 60 ans aujourd'hui parce qu'elles ont
vieilli mais surtout parce que la
fréquentation de la télévision
aujourd'hui globalement on voit bien sur
les grands programmes généralistes cette
fréquentation alors nous avons nous ne
vieillirons pas depuis un peu plus d'un
an nous stabilisons mais nous restons
assez âgées avec toutefois des taux avec
des taux toute façon intéressant sur les
25 50
alors pour autant et ça je le revendique
aussi très fortement
nous avons eu toute une série
d'émissions et je pense notamment des
émissions d'après midi sur france 3 ou
des émissaires des émissions de soirée
sur lesquels nous avons un public pour
le coup très âgées mais ça fait partie
de notre mission
ça fait partie de notre mission que de
toucher tous les publics et notamment
les publics les plus âgés qui sont chez
eux à la maison ou qui n'ont pas accès à
d'autres loisirs et donc c'est
fondamental pour le service public et il
est fondamental pour le service public
que nous puissions être ce rendez-vous
intergénérations où un certain nombre de
nos programmes touche aussi ses publics
là qui ne sont pas visés par les par les
chaînes par les chaînes privées sur le
plan de départ vous dire simplement de
choses le plan de départ de 900
personnes qui a été initié qui va se
terminer en fin d'année et qui va
toucher à l'arrivée à peu près 600
personnes 650 est un plan de départ qui
était un plan particulier puisque
c'était en réalité un plan de départ à
la retraite un peu accéléré c'est à dire
que toute personne qui avait ses
annuités pouvait partir avec une
incitation
c'est donc ce n'était pas un plan qui
permettait de réorganiser mais puisqu'un
plan qui permet de réorganiser est un
plan qui dit voilà lé secteur sur lequel
je voudrais organiser et c'est un plan
qui d'ailleurs qui a été lancé
un an et demi avant avant que je
n'arrive à la tête de l'entreprise qui a
nécessité des remplacements en
proportions très importantes qui font
faire une économie induite par ce que un
nouvel entrant et moins rémunérés qu'une
personne à l'âge de la retraite mais qui
en tout cas n'a pas eu d'effet en termes
de restructuration de l'entreprise
ce sur quoi nous devons aujourd'hui
avancée mais c'est un des éléments clés
des débats à venir
c'est la manière dont nous allons
aborder la baisse des effectifs liés en
particulier à l'entreprise nouvelle mais
monsieur le genre de la bien dit ça se
fait pas du jour au lendemain
cette baisse des effectifs nous l'avions
inscrits dans le coma - 500 et j'ai dit
aux instances représentatives du
personnel que nous allons présenter ce
plan dans l'est dans les prochains temps
ce plan pouvant être de cinq cents ou un
peu plus en fonction des éléments
d'ajustement nous aurons à faire mais il
faut pour le coup que ce soit un plan
qui permette effectivement la baisse des
effectifs et qui ne soit pas simplement
d'un plan de départs en accéléré sur le
je regarde mes notes sur les langues
régionales et la présence en région oui
nous allons évidemment autant que faire
se peut poursuivre ce travail nous avons
cette scène en comptera deux gîtes et
moyens de développer les langues
régionales
nous allons développer les offres sur le
web qui permettent de toucher des cibles
particulières après très clairement ça
va faire partie de la négociation des
objectifs et des moyens et on va faire
en fonction de nos moyens et si nous ne
parvenons pas avoir les moyens
suffisants fera peut-être un peu moins
en tout cas ça fait partie évidemment
comme la présence en région comme
l'information région et comme les
événements culturels religion de de la
légitimité du service public concernant
france 5
je t'ai demandé à bruno patino faire un
point sur tout ce qu'on fait avec les
lycées puisqu'on continue à faire
beaucoup
alors très rapidement comme vous l'avez
comme vous l'avez signalé donc nous
faisons
nous faisons des choses avec l'éducation
nationale non seulement dans le domaine
de la culture ou ciné lycée et culture
lycée ont finalement remplacé d'une
certaine façon est étendu le ciné-club
que des gens de ma génération ont pu
connaître quand il fallait aller
chercher des bobines nous avons étendu
sa et nous refondons d'ailleurs
positivement l'offre le 21 novembre lors
du 1 au moment du salon de l'étudiant
dans une offre qui va être france
télévisions éducation sur lequel nous
étendons encore tout ce que nous offrons
à la fois aux élèves et aux enseignants
et donc au lycée et aux établissements
scolaires qui sont qui sont qui sont là
dessus donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est assez peu connu du
grand public mais c'est très connu je
pense parler par les gens qui sont dans
les documents des centres de
documentation dans les lycées par les
différents établissements scolaires mais
ça marche ça marche bien c'est une offre
qui marche bien et qui permet je le dis
pour pour pour l'ensemble des gens ici
de proposer dans un contexte à la fois
pédagogique et avec un ensemble de
fiches pédagogiques et de fiches
contextualise abl l'ensemble des
émissions à caractère j'allais dire
éducatif au sens large du terme puisque
même les grands documentaires comme
comme apocalypse ou autres ils sont
vraiment dans un cadre scolaire
ça ça c'est ce qui est et est le
développement de sa est prévue non mais
le développement continu le vous vous
verrez qu'en novembre l'offre ça nous a
pris un an sera complètement refondu est
beaucoup plus étendu à la fois en termes
de programmes qui sont proposés de
fiches pédagogiques qui sont réalisées
avec l'aide de l'éducation nationale et
le partenariat continu continu de façon
très positive
quant à quant au ludo éducatif que vous
avez mentionné comme comme vous le savez
les zouzous le matin sur france 5 ça
reste du ludo éducatif c'est à dire des
programmes certes pour la jeunesse non
scolarisés encore mais qui vise à
apprendre quelque chose pendant qu'on
est devant le téléviseur pour ça qu'on
est souvent que ces programmes jeunesse
préféré des parents on essaie qu'il soit
aussi préféré des enfants
mais dans cette démarche là et donc
comme l'a signalé le président de france
télévisions nous avons étendu
ça à la fois aux applications nous en
avions parlé lors d'une audition
précédente à des applications
spécifiques qui permettent dans le cadre
de programmes ludo éducatifs aux parents
à la fois de suivre la progression du
dow éducative de leurs enfants mais
aussi de limiter le temps d' écoute et
pour les enfants d'y avoir accès à peu
près en permanence et nous lançons ça
dans les semaines qui viennent sur les
services de télévision connectée alors
les services de télévision connectée
c'est très limité pour le moment en
terme de foyers connectés mais ça ne le
sera pas tout le temps et donc bientôt
l'ensemble des foyers connectés via leur
téléviseur pourront avoir cette chaîne
ludo-éducatif permanente
puisqu'on parle de france 5 mme la
présidente félicitons-nous qui reçoit
france 5 en première partie de soirée a
battu son record de tous les temps avec
un documentaire que deux millions de
personnes qui ont regardé un
documentaire sur enquête de santé
concernant le lait voilà nous en sommes
très très fiers et c'est bien là aussi
la différenciation du service pulsé fait
longtemps qu'on vous vante les atouts de
la culture scientifique
depuis le 10 et de l'est
via monsieur le président je vous
remercie de ses riches
réponse je proposerai à mes collègues au
prochain bureau de notre commission que
nous installions début 2013
parmi nos groupes de travail un groupe
de travail sur les droits
le partage des droits sans préjuger des
conclusions mais un diagnostic partagé
serein sans a priori me semble
absolument nécessaire sur ce sujet et le
sénat sera dans son rôle en
approfondissant la question voilà pour
l'audition de rémy pflimlin le pdg de
france télévisions devant les sénateurs
de la commission de la culture
si vous souhaitez revoir ses travaux
cette audition est disponible sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr bonne
journée à tous